but first we turn to our top story out
of Chicago once again embattled Empire
actor Jesse Smollett he is still
proclaiming his innocence after being
formally accused of orchestrating what
is an elaborate hate crime hoax and
charged with a felony and smaller posted
bond he went directly to the set of
Empire it is reported that he told the
cast and crew quote I swear to God I did
not do this but according to TMZ many of
his co-stars they're not buying it and
they are bleeping furious and today
producers announced that small its role
on Empire has been cut from the final
two episodes now Jesse small as lawyers
there correct
he must be assumed innocent presumption
of innocence before being proven guilty
with that said the evidence against him
as presented by the Chicago Police
yesterday and others is now overwhelming
and frankly beginning to border on
incontrovertible and according to
prosecutors Smollett paid these two
brothers thousands of dollars to stage a
homophobic racist assault against the
actor on the streets of Chicago using a
news bleach all while wearing red Magga
hats make America great again hack hats
and ski masks both of those individuals
have been testifying both before the
grand jury and to the police against
mullet and as you can see right there
that video evidence shows that pair
buying the items used allegedly in the
assault surveillance also shows the
brothers arrival at the scene of the
incident phone records indicate Smollett
called the brothers both before and
right after this staged attack and text
exchanges spell out how Smollett
solicited their help and perhaps the
most damning and most puzzling piece of
evidence he paid the accomplices with a
check kind of aka Jerry Springer now
naturally the spin has already started
Smollett allegedly he's trying to tell
the police he had an untreated drug
problem texts indicate that in fact the
actor may have purchased the party drug
drug known as Molly or ecstasy from one
of the brothers involved in this hoax
so is he saying the drugs made him do it
but I didn't do it
well except X the
see or Mali has never been known to
cause any hate crime hoax and meanwhile
conspiracy TV MSNBC they're toting a
brand-new conspiracy maybe the Chicago
Police are just lying take a look this
Police Department did in 2016 open lead
through their union support Donald Trump
and a lot of this case has been focused
on the magg statements so to have a
police department that hasn't been as
cooperative as they have been this round
do not openly give information do openly
lie and Mis hold information in cases
and then to know that they are openly
have openly supported on Trump in the
2016 election a lot of activists on the
ground are saying wait what's going on
here who do we believe out of these two
suspect people now of course most and
the media mob the hate Trump media mob
are coming to grips with the smallest
story the only way they know how
blame Trump some more everything's
Trump's fault the dog bites the beast
things if you're feeling sad its drums
fault yep incredibly the hate Trump
media mob has now officially lost any
sense of reality in a complete state of
hate Trump psychosis
take a look are a lot of evidence
violent incidents that happened at these
Magma's and I just don't want to get you
know have Jesse Smollett distract from
that now obviously we're not going to
put what happened on Trump but we can
put on Trump clearly is the heightened
panic and angst today you know folks
that believe Jesse as a default position
we feel sadness today we don't feel
stupid today I feel bad for the people
who did not default to that empathy who
think that this is a game who are
gloating today those people have
something fundamentally wrong with them
are you listening to this this hate
Trump media Bob loses it when president
Trump calls them out for fake news which
they are but what they're doing is even
worse they continually rush to judgment
it's always guilt by accusation but only
if you're a Republican or conservative
pushing blatantly false stories
conspiracy theories impugning the
character of millions of Americans now
even teenagers that may
Magga hat why to push their favorite
narrative every second minute hour of
every 24-hour day every week month year
Trump's evil supporters are evil and
they are morally superior this is why
fake victimhood is on the rise now
attention-seeking Trump haters know that
they will garner sympathy almost
immediately and fame from the media
because it advances their narrative all
while impugning the character of Trump
supporters in the process and so in the
era of Trump we see hoaxes after hoax
after hoax very little reporting on it
remember racist graffiti on a building
at Eastern Michigan University staged by
a former student woman in New York
saying that Oh a group of proteins
vandalized her car while yelling Trump
2016
turned out she vandalized her own car
homophobic slurs spray-painted on the
side of an Indiana church by the church
organ player look at the side of your
screen
fake hate crimes are far too common in
this country and time and time again
this media mob and Democrats if it fits
their agenda they buy these stories hook
line sinker constantly rushing to
judgment and by the way they hold up
each eventual hoax as a shining example
of why Trump supporters are horrible
people and it remember where they're
smelling Walmart people
the irredeemable deplorable we cling to
our God Bibles guns and religion and in
doing so they ruin the reputation and in
some cases the lives of very good
honorable decent people and when the
truth is revealed
crickets they just move on to the next
fake news story no apologies no
accountability no mayor Copa no nothing
this is what happened in the case of
Richard Jewell remember I thought it was
so bad in 1996 the media mob there
accused him of being the olympic bomber
why cuz he lived with his mother I was
on the air at the time Richard was
listening I said that's the most idiotic
Theory I've ever heard
turns out he was a hero but watch this
you've got Jay Leno referring to Richard
is you know doofus the New York Post
referring to him as a Rando the Atlanta
journal-constitution calling him
everything from a villain to a person
seeking the limelight and overzealous
fool everybody in the world thinks that
he bombed the park because the way he's
been portrayed in the media if they
could fool me someone who's supposed to
be educated and experienced in being
fair and objective and reaching solid
conclusions if they could fool me then
boy they fooled a lot of people and as
bad as it was then it is so much worse
with the media mob today that attorney
you saw is Lynwood he found some justice
thankfully for his client through the
civil court system but jewel has since
passed away at a really young age I
believe and so does Lynwood that the
stress of all of that helped contribute
to his heart condition and what the
media put him through was pure hell
Lynwood now representing Covington high
school student Nicholas Sandman who was
the latest victim a 16 year old kid now
of the mobs politically-motivated
anti-trump rushed to judgment this mob
their attacks on Nicholas Sandman were
so insane many even on fake news CNN
conspiracy TV MSNBC and elsewhere
actually started to talk about the
racist scourge of red make America hats
okay a hat that says make this country
great again is a trigger what's next not
guilty of a crime maybe somebody
suffering from hate Trump derangement
syndrome what's this it has become an
invitation for confrontation some have
even referred to the Hat as a modern-day
version of the Confederate battle flag
the Hat in some ways represents for many
of us a kind a kind of racial animus the
maggot hat carries a certain connotation
that provokes a conditioned reaction for
many people especially for marginalized
people just think about this symbol of
that red hat
when I see the make America great again
hat now Chris I am triggered a red make
America great again hat caused me to do
these things and all these hate Trump
media blaming a fake hate crime on a hat
actually hate crimes are going totally
unreported where was the media hysteria
over attacks where Trump supporters were
punched kicked assault at harass stalk
all because of their political beliefs
Don Lemon have you ever covered that
Robin Roberts anyone else in the hate
Trump media you talk about the rise in
the far-left hatred or obsess about the
physical attacks on people merely
wearing a red Magga hat why how many of
these people support black lives matter
what do we want dead cops what do we
want them now pigs in a blanket fry them
like bacon bacon
it doesn't fit their narrative those
people don't seem to matter if you're
conservative where our make America
great again hat and it's why we've seen
little to no coverage of this vicious
assault from earlier this week from
supporter activists brutally punched
he's trying to videotape the whole thing
over his political beliefs we don't know
everything but happen but it three
witnesses confirm his story take a look
hayden williams is the kid that just got
coal [ __ ] in that particular video we're
letting the facts play out so forth
three eyewitnesses support his story
that he was assaulted he said it was
over a pro trump sign mainstream media
silence no rushing to judgment here fact
pretty much no coverage at all but what
else should we expect from a mainstream
media that is actively working on behalf
of the Democratic Party first to stop
Donald Trump from ever becoming
president you know but now they want to
impugn the character of millions of
Americans that support the president
that like the success in our economy
that like the 5.3 million new jobs will
have a lot more on this coming up but
first a quick update on our Hannity
watch of Muller's witch-hunt the probe
is reportedly now in its final stages
there were earlier reports this week
that it would wrap up in the report will
be delivered to the DOJ next week but
according to a great new article from
kimberly strauss oh look at this Oh
Democrats are anticipating a huge
letdown with no collusion literally
written on the wall at this point
conspiracy theorists house Intel
committee chair biggest liar in Congress
and I can prove it Adam Schiff he's
plotting his backup plan I'm sure the
media will follow suit and it's
something that we have warned about for
months
that means non-stop never-ending endless
frivolous expensive pointless
investigations on the same topic and
President Trump and his family and
anybody associated with him they know
they'll find nothing but it gives
Democrats a venue to continue what has
been two years of never-ending smear and
slander and innuendo and can
Spira see theories and character
assassination of Donald Trump and
anybody that likes his shifty shift an
excuse to do his favorite activity lie
to you We the People